on the season finale of gen V you just
can't go around killing people
why what do you mean why cuz you can't
why well if you're like me you finished
the season finale of gen V and we're
like what the [__] we have a crazy twist
ending a mid credit scene and a cameo
from everyone's favorite familyfriendly
superhero if you're wondering who Jeff
was working undercover for how VA
Twisted the massacre at gulan or even
where Marie and the Gang are I have
theor for all of that and more in this
video so let's get into it and make sure
to like And subscribe yeah sure whatever
we have a lot to get into it's not every
day you get your Dean to commit suicide
Marie and the Gang are left stunned
after Kate offed Dean and DEA Shetty the
woman responsible for the creation of a
soup killing virus which is now
conveniently in the hands of vice
presidential candidate Victoria Newman
what could go wrong a lot is happening
Dean Shetty tasked Kate with killing the
remaining prisoners in the woods an
underground testing facility created by
VA to learn how soups work but
unbeknownst to VA Dean Shetty went rogue
and developed an Airborne virus to kill
all soups in season one of the boys the
Dean's husband and daughter died aboard
trans Oceanic Flight 37 the flight
homelander and mave saved from Terrace
only to let it crash into the ocean I
tend to believe the theory that
homelander wanted the plane to crash in
an attempt to sway public opinion in
allowing soups into the military if they
let us into the military then this will
never happen again to the dean
homelander VA and all soups are a
destructive force that needs to be wiped
out at any cost so when Kate decides to
kill the dean she believes she's doing
something good when I'm done maybe
eventually you'll realize I'm being a
hero this is a really tragic decision
for Kate as the dean was kind of a
mother figure for her in episode 6 we
saw how Kate's parents locked her away
from afraid that she'll hurt others with
her power the dean was the first person
to love Kate for who she is to not be
afraid of her but this turned out to be
one giant manipulation and that feeling
of betrayal by Kate surely factored into
her decision to kill her Kate believes
the inmates of the woods should be set
free and she won't let Marie Jordan or
Emma stop her and in a surprising twist
Sam joins her remember this is a guy who
just a few episodes ago almost killed
Kate trust me right
Let Her Go Kate was responsible for
wiping golden boy's memories so that
he'd forget he even had a brother and
for years Sam was tested on had needles
injected into his spine and was
imprisoned below the university he only
sees humans as evil just like Shetty
only saw soups as such and even though
Emma tells Sam not to help Kate Sam goes
anyway maybe it's time for me to save
you meanwhile Andre waits for news about
his father last episode we saw saw him
experience violent seizures which caused
his magnetic powers to almost crush him
and his son to death he's been taken to
VA Tower and I love this quick insert
shot where you can see it's being
repaired after the giant battle between
the boys and soldier boy at the end of
season 3 take note here of his hospital
gown it looks a little familiar to some
gowns we'll see later on but more on
that in a bit the dock here says that
every time polarity uses his powers it
creates a micro tear in his brain and
over time this led to these seizures
it's something that cannot be reversed
this has huge implications for not just
polarity but for Andre polarity will no
longer be able to use his powers I mean
he can but he risks killing himself
doing so for a guy whose entire Persona
revolves around his superpower this news
is catastrophic for Andre it begs the
question about his future he's probably
tearing his brain after he uses his
powers I love how the doctor asked him
if he's experienced any ticks and just
check out his facial expressions here
later in the episode Andre will land a
helicopter with his power and if that
didn't cause a tear in his brain surely
it would have caused one in my pants I
don't know what I'm saying Andre hasn't
talked to his father since learning he
was complicit in what was happening with
the woods don't say another word about
this it's important to know that
polarity had no knowledge of Dean shed's
soup killing virus so polarity
apologizes to Andre stating that what he
did was to protect Andre and his family
but I got to say po was just being the
good little soldier doing whatever V
told him and this is what he wants for
Andre too telling him that he's done
with school just put his head down do
whatever vot tells you and even has his
costume refitted so that it fits Andre
even though Andre tries to tell his
father their powers are killing them
polarity tells his son to take up the
mantle and do what is right for their
family this is the sacrifice polarity
made and now he's wanting Andre to make
it too you're going to be a better
polarity than I ever was so it looks
like next season we'll see Andre
struggling over whether or not to use
his powers and follow in his Father's
Footsteps to me this whole micro tear
thing brings up the question of whether
or not other soups will be affected by
soup specific ailments we haven't really
gotten our first generation of geriatric
soup so as they get older they'll be
faced with new diseases disabilities and
illnesses that the medical field has yet
to see the wild card here is Marie we
still don't know the extent of her
powers and I can't help but think that
she may able to heal those micro tears
speaking of brain problems at the end of
season 3 of the boys Billy butcher is
diagnosed with brain lesions after
taking six doses of compound v24 the
compound that gives you powers for 24
hours he's given 12 to 18 months to live
polarity also is my number one guess at
who will take over as the new Dean of
gulkan he's a trustee and a VA Yes Man
and now that he shouldn't use his powers
a more administrative rule may be just
what he needs Ashley Barrett CEO of va
has made her way to campus later in the
video I'll talk about how Ashley isn't
the real CEO and this may have something
to do with the events that unfold at the
end of the episode this past semester
has been an absolute [__] show from
Golden Boy fertilizing the lawn with his
guts the cluster fudge that was Victoria
Newman's town hall and application rates
to gulan have plummeted totally off
topic but it would be really cool if we
saw other rival soup universities in
order to distract the public from this
mess Ash has come to gulan to choose a
new member of the seven and who do we
see here none other than Andre Anderson
it's pretty gross how all vot cares
about his branding and Optics let's be
honest they don't give a [__] about GPA
hell the deep is one of the seven my new
motto for mental health realiz realize
[Music]
realiz Andre's right up here shows how
he could be a potential brand and risk
having been friends with the vilified
Golden Boy and His rocky relationship
with polarity but he does have an
additional skill a British accent
something he showed off in the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina abstinence is
encouraged what the hell there's also a
brief mention of his mother Leila who
ran polarity brand we don't know much
about her other than she's deceased
meanwhile Kate and Sam undertake their
rescue of the woods Kate mistakenly
calls this guard Greg which has been a
running joke throughout the season Greg
uh I'm Bob Bob I'm Greg hey Greg will
clean up later let's go using her
ability Kate gets the guard to open the
cells where we're introduced to a host
of new soups there's teleport guy sweaty
melt yourf face guy and Laser Eye girl
it must be a weird experience for Sam to
return here but when he looks into his
cell he's haunted by a vision of his
brother throughout the episode we'll see
Golden Boy act as Sam's conscience
telling him not to go through killing
innocent people it actually gets so bad
bad that he asked Kate to make him feel
nothing I feel so empty one of the
things I found a bit awkward this
episode was Kate letting out the inmates
not knowing whether or not they might
carry this virus I don't know about you
guys but if I saw Andy over here who
died from it then met sweaty guy I'd be
like uh let's uh slow this down a bit
whether this sweat is caused by his
heating power or the virus is never
known but the way the show kind of just
brushes the S Suggest it's part of his
power it's seeing Andy's body that
actually fuels the others to commit
these Mass crimes against innocent
humans they've been subject to such
cruelty it's time for Revenge e your own
fing hands you monster with the inmates
free all hell breaks loose with
Professor ranata abara who we actually
saw in episode three having her face
melted with Marie Emma and Jordan
arriving at the woods too late they
decide to split up and stop the
marauding bands of murderous soups Marie
will hit the campus alarm Emma will
alert the others and Jordan will rescue
Ashley and the gulan trustees the
episode's first big twist involves
everyone's favorite social media
director Jeff # blackl magic he's been
secretly working undercover for an
unknown person or organization in The
Season's second episode we learned he
tripped on the red carpet while
attending paleyfest but who knows if
that's even true considering we now know
he's this undercover agent in this EP
he's all healed now but who could he be
working for let's lay out everything we
know about him he knows about the woods
telling the electricity soup she should
have stayed in her cage he has no
remorse for the soups in the woods is
not a soup himself since he's not
affected by the Sonic whistle and he has
access to some higher end Tech like the
whistle and head exploding discs he also
controls the University's social media
so he's heavily involved in the
dissemination of information there are
three theories on who he could be
working for and I'll put them in order
of what I think is strongest the first
is Ashley Barrett and VA how else could
you be given this Tech like the Sonic
whistle which we previously saw only
held by VA guards within the woods with
all the [__] going on at gulan I'm sure
Ashley would want someone on the inside
keeping her up to date on everything
plus Jeff also tries to get soups to
promote vot products and takes
legitimate care in his role as a social
media manager no it's perfect just just
take a sip say turbo Rush K's hangovers
the two other people he could be working
for are the boys or Victoria Newman but
the reason I lean more towards Ashley
and VA is that it seems the boys and
Newman only learned about the woods last
episode yet Jeff has been working here
for at least the beginning of the
semester there is a small chance he
could be working for Victoria or the
Federal Bureau of superhuman Affairs if
Victoria actually knew about the woods
before Marie told her about it last
episode it's hinted that Victoria and
Dean Shetty may have known one another
since it was Victoria who ensured Marie
got into gulkan and that Marie wouldn't
be given over to Dr cardosa as one of
his test subjects Jeff also tells the
person on the other line quote rehab
might be unlocked this appears to be a
reference to the escaped inmates into
the woods as a rehab that could be used
to suppress or take away one's Powers
bonus points if you caught that the dude
the electricity soup explodes here is
the same guy who gave Andre vurger in
episode 5 kind of holding up the line
there dog back in the boardroom Ashley
and the trustees look over Maverick as a
potential member of the seven he is
translucent son after all but this is
interrupted by Kate pushing Jeff to
commit suicide live on his social media
in Adam bork's class Liam performs a
monologue from the smashit film dawn of
the s a movie which we saw filming in
the boys season 2 and the premiere of at
the beginning of the boys season 3 I'm a
lot like
you I'm gay classes cut short however
with the arrival of Sam who almost ends
up choking Adam to death fortunately
Emma arrives just in the nick of time to
get her heart broken over the past few
episodes Emma and Sam have developed a
romantic relationship sh but Sam's
radicalization and Lust For Revenge
Cloud his judgment in fact he says the
most hurtful thing he could possibly say
to Emma you're not a hero Emma started
the season off resigned to a life of
acting she'd probably go about her life
as some sort of reality TV star and not
a real hero but over the course of the
Season she's tried to prove to herself
and others that she has what it takes to
be one perhaps this is why she was so
adamant to help Andre in his attempt to
break out Sam in episode 3 after crying
the camera pushes back to reveal Emma
has shrunk we know that in order for her
to get small she has to purge so the
question arises can she also get small
by crying I mean both are bodily fluids
being expelled from the body just don't
ask me what happens when she poops
that's disgusting Sam has to make a
choice continue with Kate and hold
humans accountable for the crimes
they've committed or listen to Golden
Boy stop Kate because what they're doing
is murdering in innocent people Sam ends
up siding with Kate after realizing
Golden Boy is a figment of his
imagination Harper and Justine the girl
you may remember getting her jaw busted
by Jordan last episode stream the
massacre as Marie hits the alarm putting
the school in lockdown but worst of all
no Wi-Fi oh my God I just lost Wi-Fi the
alarm not only shuts down the campus
with these metal doors but it triggers a
vast network of Sonic whistles harming
only soups within range it begs the
question question were the lockdowns
ever really for the protection of the
students in the background we can make
out a display for a student named Alexis
gorch she is currently ranked number
nine at gulan so it's possible they were
considering her for the seven job as
well the Sonic whistle is shortlived
however when one of the inmates uses his
scream attack to disable the alarm also
bonus points if you heard the Wilhelm
scream
here Ashley tells her assistant also
Ashley yes that's her official character
name to find homelander in radio in for
the helicopter this wouldn't be also
Ashley's first experience with a
helicopter as she was denied access to
one after vot Tower was evacuated in the
boys season 3 with you Ashley to the
helipad yeah so the sakori is actually
reserved for svps and hire a desperate
Ashley has her and the other trustees
call the potential candidates and offer
them the seven job if they kill these
Rogue soups we know that Marie has
always wanted to be in the seven but
even this seems a bit too far for her
that is until Ashley offers her
something even bigger the chance to meet
her sister all we really know about
Marie's sister is that she was placed
into foster care after the murder of her
parents in episode 2 Haley Miller tells
Marie that they contacted her sister who
wanted nothing to do with her but Shetty
says in the next episode that was likely
a tactic to get Marie flustered before
getting on camera we also don't know if
Marie's sister has powers it's likely
that she does considering her parents
gave Marie compound V would they not do
the same to her sister Kate pushes a
soup to knock down the approaching vot
helicopter but Andre uses all his might
to land it safely and Andre here looks
absolutely messed up after doing this no
doubt this is causing those micro tears
in the very fabric of his brain he tells
marray that he'll try to talk to Kate
and Marie refers to the two of them as
the Guardians of gulan a name that was
taken away from him after he missed his
big interview in episode 2 now that
she's off her meds Kate tells Andre that
she can push a heck of a lot more before
passing out the drugs had been limiting
her powers all these years and even
though Andre tells her they're on the
same side are they does Andre really
want to be like his dad a man who was
complicit in VA schemes a man who knew
about what was going on in the woods and
yet did nothing meanwhile Marie has to
fight off Maverick something that proves
it difficult considering he's invisible
last episode we saw Victoria encouraging
Marie to focus on her blood finally able
to see the compound V flowing through it
Marie focuses here as well well soon
being able to sense Maverick's blood to
identify him and take him out and while
Jordan takes on screamer suit we see my
new favorite background
actor Andre tells Kate they can figure
this all out and Kate offers her non-g
gloved hand but when Andre hesitates in
taking it she knows Andre doesn't trust
her Sam storms in and the two battle it
out with Andre using his powers to grab
a taser and knock Sam out Marie tells
Kate that all she ever wanted was to be
a her hero someone her sister could be
proud of but now she doesn't care about
being a hero she just wants to be a good
person but Kate reiterates that she's
trying to save Marie and others like her
with VA they are not treated as people
but as products their confrontation is
cut short when Jordan is attacked by
three of the woods prisoners with Marie
giving laser girl over here a heart
attack another inmate goes for Ashley
Adam and the trustees who have taken
refuge in the downed helicopter and it's
here we see one of the most badass parts
of the episode episode where Marie takes
the blood of nearby corpses to create
these blood shards to kill the
approaching soup it's here that things
seem to settle down but not before Kate
approaches Jordan to push him but Marie
is like bye
[__] and spontaneously explodes her
hand before anything can be done we hear
the sound barrier being broken as
homelander descends on campus and just
listen to how dissonant his music is
here
it's assumed that homelander is
currently on trial for the death of a
Starlight supporter at the end of season
3 but that he's on some sort of bail and
allowed to continue his work as part of
the seven homelander was called here by
Ashley and in a huge twist asked Marie
if she's an animal for harming one of
her own kind over the course of the
first three seasons of the boys we've
seen homelander become more and more
radical in his views on soups versus
Humans just listen to how he talks to at
train after killing a soup in season 3
how could you kill kill one of your own
kind in Cold Blood it's kind of
hypocritical considering homelander has
killed many soups including black noir
but by far the biggest WTF moment is
what happens after Marie is blasted by
homelanders laser eyes we find out that
vot has spun the entire Massacre to be
the result of Emma Marie Andre and
Jordan and it would have been far worse
if it weren't for the new guardians of
gulan Sam and Kate we'll see homelander
watching the news at VA Tower with a
smile on his face remember that
homelander has full control over VA with
Ashley acting as a public figurehead
with the title he did this after outing
Stan Edgar so it can be assumed that
homelander orchestrated this whole thing
and has interests that are separate from
that of Ashley's at the end of season 3
Ashley saw that mave was still alive and
deleted the security footage something
she's kept secret from homelander as a
small Act of rebellion we know that Sam
and Kate both hate VA so why would
homelander not not only spare them but
make them the new guardians of gulkan
that's because the three of them share
something in common a hatred for humans
I'm glad you chose your own kind that
was smart if I'm Sam Kate and homelander
comes to me after this event and says
look I hate humans too and if you follow
me I'll make sure we do something about
it that's like the best deal ever but it
still doesn't explain where Marie Jordan
Emma and Andre are when Marie awakens
from her injury she finds herself along
with the others in a circular hospital
room with no doors there is a door it's
just done the ceiling here with one of
those wheel handle thingies you'd
normally see on a naval vessel note the
vot hospital gowns which appear to be
identical to the ones a train wore at VA
Tower in season 3 and polarity in VA
Tower this episode so we're likely at VA
Tower or at least a facility owned and
operated by VA homelander wouldn't have
outright killed these kids seeing has
he's already wanted for murder and that
probably wouldn't have been a good look
so while they may be imprisoned they are
definitely not being treated like
genocidal murderers first it looks like
they're getting fantastic care second
they're allowed to be in the same room
together and third Emma even has a
smoothie wait hold on a second there's a
fourth does Andre have his phone here
Jordan Emma and Andre don't even seem to
be that concerned they're not panicked
at all trying to find a way out so I
think they know where they are I will
note the security cameras here so
someone is definitely watching them
their good treatment may be the result
of Ashley after all these guys saved her
life so if they're going to get out of
here I wouldn't be surprised if Ashley
is the one to help Ashley knows how
messed up and unhinged homelander is so
I would expect her in the upcoming
season of the boys to undermine his
authority and what happens if homelander
gets convicted of murder you really
think he's going to jail all hell will
break loose if that happens we already
saw in episode 7 at the Town Hall a soup
questioning the impartiality of the
human jurors in the case can a soup be
fairly judged by a jur J of human peers
now if you stuck a little bit longer
through the credits you'll get this
super brief scene of Billy butcher
discovering the woods timeline wise we
don't really know when this is in
relation to the massacre at gulan with
all the [__] going down there and Grace
learning from Shetty of the creation of
a soup killing virus on campus it's not
a surprise to see a member of the boys
here if Billy and the boys find out more
about the woods it may uncover
homelander and vot's coverup of the
massacre or even Victoria Newman's
possession of the virus whatever might
be in store for us for the boy season 4
it definitely looks like the writers
have a lot to play with but what do you
think is going to happen I want to hear
your thoughts and theories in the
comments below thanks for watching
please be sure to like And subscribe and
for more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at@ thinkstory YT
until next time remember holy
[__] a lot is
happening yeah